- I'm waiting for her to get shocked.
- I'm not getting shocked.
- I'm waiting for you to get shocked.
- I don't lie.
(laughs)
(bubbly music)
- Today, we are going to be complimenting each other
with a toy lie detector.
- I am a gas up queen.
I will gas anybody up.
You do that thing, camera!
You better record.
We compliment each other a lot.
^- [Host] Do you mean it?
- Yeah.
- I think so, I mea...
- Hey, what?
- I mean like
- You don't trust me?
Wait are you saying you don't mean it
when you compliment me?
- I'm just saying like, "Why not?"
"Why wouldn't we?"
You know?
- This feels already like a betrayal.
- If I compliment you first I mean it, because I initiated.
If you compliment me, I have to scramble
to think of a compliment, because that's just the rules.
- Huh.
I don't feel that way.
(laughter)
- So, you need to like strap yourself in.
- Oh, yeah.
- So you can't escape.
^So, what happens if you lie?
^- [Host] It shocks you.
- What?
- You are very smart, like when I hired you
and when you went out for that interview
you had so many ideas and things going on.
Like, you do a lot of deep diving strategizing.
- Wow, thanks Izzy.
That means a lot.
- Destinee, your nails are so cute.
It's the truth.
It's true, it's very true.
- We about to find out.
(dings)
- Okay.
- Oh my god, that's scary.
- I hate this.
That's the truth.
(laughs)
Yep, I hate this.
- I like your sense of style.
- That's right.
Are we supposed to just wait?
(dings)
- I guess I am telling the truth.
- I mean, how do you like this shit?
- I like everything.
- See, I met you in my intern class
and you were the best friend from my intern class
and now you are my real best friend in real life too.
And I love you.
(dings)
- Aw, that was so nice!
That was so cute.
- It didn't shock me.
- Yay!
- I think you have gorgeous, flawless skin.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, sis.
- I should have waited.
I should have waited.
- But it's the truth.
So, you know?
(screams)
No, I meant it!
I mean it.
- Wow. I'm leaving.
- I really do like your skin!
- I really like your shirt.
It's a really nice shirt.
(laughs)
^- [Host] Did it shock you?
- Yeah.
- Does that mean it's...
Wait, you're lying?
- I mean, you have a great sense of humor.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
It's true.
She has a great...
(shrieks)
- Wait, you lied?
- Destinee, your poof looks great today.
- I'm waiting for her to get shocked.
- I'm not getting shocked.
- I'm waiting for you to get shocked.
- I don't lie.
(laughs)
- I knew it!
Cause I readjusted my poof and I was like,
"This don't feel right."
- That was traumatizing.
- Uh, I like your jeans.
- It's worse because I know it's not true.
- I didn't get shocked though.
- Oh my god.
It's because you've been doing it for so long probably.
You said, "When people compliment me,
I throw a compliment right back.
Like, your body even thinks it's true.
- I think you have a really bubbly, warm personality.
- That is a lie, cause I don't.
I don't at all.
You about to get shocked.
- Let the lie detector speak for itself.
(dings)
I am just so great at complimenting people.
- Wow.
- TBH.
- I like your ankle bracelet.
I do, I really like it.
It is really pretty.
- Genuinely?
- It's like really nice, stylish.
- Did you get shocked?
- I didn't.
- You really do?
- No. I was trying to lie!
I get so much shit about the ankle bracelet.
Man, my mom gives me so much shit about it.
Look, it's a memory.
- Of what? From what?
- It's like from college.
- What'd you go to college in the 90's?
- This was good.
This was a good exercise.
- It was.
- There was no lies.
- No.
- [Sequoia] Except for a couple things, but we ain't lie.
- [Desiree] What can you do?
- [Sequoia] It wasn't a lie.
- [Desiree] I will stick to it, that I had lied.
- [Sequoia] Same.
Shocked the hell out of my though.
- [Desiree] That shocked the hell out of me.
- I want to give you a hug but this feels weird.
Here, give me a hug anyway.